[Music]
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'm happy to be
here talking about the third episode of
season three of for all mankind because
what an episode most of what happened
was predictable in the most satisfying
way and then there were a couple of
things that really stirred the pot i
feel like karen's reaction to ed's
announcement at the helios meeting was a
perfect representation of how i probably
looked while watching some of this play
out the good news is we're back in space
the race is on danny's stalking
storyline is over for at least a couple
of years but the bad news is that ed
needs to rely on him in one of mankind's
most ambitious endeavors and we know
what we're watching here and that things
will most certainly go wrong so i'm
going to break down everything that
happened in the episode tell you what i
think about it right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episode 3 of for all mankind's third
season yet then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it at the end of the last
episode everything got turned on its
head as ed defected to helios and they
announced that they're planning to leave
for mars in 1994. margot has to call a
meeting and tells everyone that
president hart wants them to keep up the
pace which presents a lot of problems
considering they were barely going to be
ready for the 96 launch window because
of the planet's respective orbits ideal
conditions for launching a trip come
around every 26 months the problem with
moving things up is that their trip is
dependent on launching all the supplies
ahead of time so that they're already
there waiting when sojourner one arrives
this is all the necessary stuff like the
habitation modules they'll live in the
life support systems and fuel generators
so they can run things while they're
there and return back to earth they do
find solutions for how they can move
things around and how they can get
everything ready and then elena comes up
with the idea of launching the supplies
towards venus to use that to slingshot
it back towards mars it will take longer
than doing it in the window but it'll
still beat danielle and her crew there
by a few months unsurprisingly the
soviets announced that they'll follow
suit and now we know why we saw at the
end of season 2 that there were people
on mars in 1995. in her debate with bill
clinton on the campaign trail you see
ellen score some points by being for the
accelerated timeline this is something
americans can get behind
seeing her in this different arena away
from her astronaut life underlines how
much everything is going to change in
the future of this series it was great
to see that nasa ingenuity and everyone
working together to solve these problems
one more time but by the end of this
episode you have to wonder who will even
be there after the dust settles elada is
poised to take over if margot goes down
but who is left to take over for dany as
she ages out in orbit you see that the
polaris hotel looks a lot different now
those methane engines have been added
and it's becoming the phoenix deb is
taking ed and karen on a tour he
mentioned some of the upgrades and some
mobile hab modules and that they have
added triple redundancies to make sure
the thrusters don't malfunction again
there's a moment where karen stops as
she walks past the elevator where sam
died that reminds us of what happened
the last time they used this ship and
when they get to the flight deck the
inevitable happens dev starts laying out
his vision for things he wants to
automate most of the flight controls and
load up the crew with scientists and
even a poet and it almost feels like a
setup because obviously if you're
bringing on this dinosaur test pilot
he's never gonna go for any of that and
of course ed objects dev then makes a
big scene of stopping the work and
apologizing for making this huge mistake
telling the crew that they need to
rework the flight control systems per
the commander of the ship immediately
and i don't know it works it makes ed
feel like he's got control but the way
it played out and the spectacle of it
feels a little fishy to me
kelly comes in to ask danielle if she'll
keep her on nasa's mission she makes her
case it's more science focused as she is
and even though she's been offered a
slot on helios's trip she wants to go on
the mission where she's not just there
because her dad is the commander she's
been searching for life in the most
inhospitable place on earth and they'll
need her expertise when they get to mars
danny seems impressed and ultimately
agrees to put her on the mission so i
guess that's at least part of the answer
about who might be at nasa in the future
later in the training sim the other
danny seems distracted and crashes which
danny finds a lot less impressive he
tells her he's got a lot going on that
he just closed on a house and so she
lets him go home and basically tells him
to go romance his wife as he leaves the
building he sees the statue of his
parents outside which is a nice touch
and then later he goes to the bar to get
drunk there's a woman there who's
flirting with him pretty heavily and he
sees karen come in so he asks her if she
wants to leave they go to the swimming
pool at his old house and the new owners
call the cops they do let him go because
he's an astronaut and they know his
famous father but they call jsc and
danny has to come to pick him up in
their conversation there's a mention of
a car crash that happened eight years
ago and he tries to play off the fact
that he's drinking again she wants him
to provoke his flight status and go get
help and tells him he needs to get
himself straight and that he should go
to his wife for help karen had come into
the outpost to try to poach aleda away
from nasa she makes her a generous offer
and goes the route of saying that if she
stays there she'll always be in margot's
shadow elena decides to stay loyal and
to make her point she shows her the moon
rock she brought back and tells her that
margot made that possible she tells her
if she has to be called margo's girl
that's a small price to pay the next
morning we catch up with her at home
with her husband who isn't thrilled she
turned on the offer it is a lot more
money they argue and she makes the case
that they're doing fine compared to
where she came from and we do hear more
that indicates that her father is
starting to show signs of dementia she
says that she hasn't seen any of that
and it's really that she's not trying to
see it and her husband points out yeah
maybe that's because she's never there
we see amber stevens at home and danny
comes in planning to tell her something
probably about his relapse and not going
to mars but before he can get into any
of it ed gives him a call and offers him
a spot on helios mission his ass is
saved and i'm not sure if that knows
what he's getting himself into by
bringing on someone who's obsessed with
his ex-wife as his wingman danny does
come into helios to try to change his
mind but he thinks this is all just
because dany needs a purpose the same
way that gordo needed a purpose when he
sent him back to the moon and with a guy
like ed that's just that no one's really
gonna change his mind he comes in to
tell his team and make the announcement
and that's when we see karen get shaken
up later at the outpost kelly breaks the
news that she'll be going with nasa and
that she was the one who asked danielle
to put her on that mission at first ed
looks hurt but he ends up being
supportive so i skipped over the cold
open because it all sets up what happens
next in that we have flashbacks to iac
conferences in london over the years
this is where margot and sergey see each
other and in the first one we see them
enter an elevator together after finally
having that drink that they talked about
at the end of season two there's clear
romantic tension that's left over from
his trip to the states but she rushes
out the door as soon as it arrives on
her floor as he stands there staring at
her longingly and i do think it's worth
mentioning that there's a very
deliberate shot to get you to notice
that he's wearing a wedding ring in this
first sequence over the years we see
that they continue to see each other
here and basically the same things
happen and it's all to play up this idea
of will they or won't they at different
points we see one of the others stop
when they get out of the elevator
or hold the door and in 1991 he finally
makes his move and touches her hand and
in this shot you can see that he's no
longer wearing that wedding ring the
setup here was great because she puts
her hand in a place where it looks like
she's inviting him to hold it but it's
all very subtle it fits with her
character there's the relief that it
finally happens and then disappointment
when the elevator stops and this other
guy gets in and they have to pretend
like nothing's going on sergey pauses
when it's time to leave hoping that
she'll follow him but because this guy
knows who they are she just says good
night and sends him away
fast forward to the present day they're
back in london and this time deb is
there laying on the charm margo and
sergey meet up again and they watch him
and discuss how his entering the space
race is changing things they have drinks
and then later while they're standing at
the bar the bartender tells them that
it's last call margot says she can use
another drink and tell sergey to grab
the bottle and it's on they don't say
anything in the elevator he uses the
bathroom and while he's in there she
looks in the mirror and it reminds you
that this moment was 10 years in the
making and we see him do the same thing
and it appears that there's this shared
reservation but we know there's more
going on with what he's thinking about
he comes out and when he starts to make
small talk and pour the drink she
interrupts saying i would like you to
kiss me it all starts out pretty awkward
it's pretty obvious that this is not
margo's comfort zone but it does start
to get hot and then sergey stops in a
monumentally unromantic move he starts
talking about work he explains that they
can't get their nuclear engine cooling
system to work and begs her and i mean
begs her to help because if he fails
there will be serious consequences she
points out that they have this agreement
they trade secrets to help each other
out as far as space is concerned but
anything that could be used for military
use is off the table he tries to bring
her around but eventually he gives up
saying he understands and that he
apologizes for everything which seems a
little out of place as soon as he says
that there's a knock at the door and
then you understand what he was saying
and before they open it there's a great
shot of her where you see that she
starts to realize what she's gotten
herself into intelligence agents come in
they show her compromising photos
they've collected showing her talking
with sergey she's still adamant about
not sharing the engine design but the
agents point out that she's been sharing
classified information with them for
nine years her comeback is that anything
she shared was for the furtherance of
space travel and in the interest of
international peace which of course is
naive and the agent points out that the
fbi would consider her a spy and a
traitor still she's willing to take that
chance and when they see that she's
serious they start strangling sergey
right in front of her the threat is
explicit if she doesn't help they'll
kill him and they give her a day to
think about it and a telephone number to
call when she's ready when she comes
back in the office we see that there's a
tear in her eye nori mentions the
delivery from neptune records which is
the way that her and sergey stayed in
touch and she tells them to send it back
in her office bill is waiting and he's
there to tell her that he's going to
helios i guess they went after him after
elena turned them down he says it's not
personal and you believe it he was
totally dedicated to nasa it's just a
whole lot of money and he explains it a
little better to elena later she doesn't
say anything to him on his way out then
after he's gone she says goodbye bill to
herself and picks up the photo of when
she was just starting that he was
looking at she puts the number the agent
gave her on her desk where we can see it
elena and bill do have their goodbyes he
almost tears up when he says that she'll
be a great flight director and she calls
him peanut to lighten the mood he says
that her and margot are like two peas in
a pod and given what we just saw with
her situation it does hint that elate is
going to be very important at nasa
there's a shot where we see her working
late at night which is something that we
know that she always does and when it
transitions to the next scene it's two
years later and it's launch day and you
guessed it she is the flight director
for the mars mission and i have to give
coral pena credit here she does these
scenes so well it really gets you pumped
up to see her in that position and it is
still a race to get there first we see
ed and danny launch from orbit on
phoenix
sojourner one lift off from the moon
it's our first shot of what the
sojourner craft looks like and then we
see the soviet mars 94 mission take off
as margot looks on considering this is
two years later that their ship is
taking off it's heavily implied that she
did give them the secrets that they
needed and you understand the
uncomfortable look on her face nori
comes in to tell her the president is on
the line and it is ellen she won a race
and now nasa is trying to win theirs and
the episode ends there
so this episode was just for all mankind
doing what it does best across the board
even when it does things it's done
before like the last minute time jump to
kick things up for the next episode it
still works like a charm there were a
lot of nice references to make us feel
at home bill raising his hand in the
meeting elena being comfortable with her
scarring alone with her husband in their
room and ed dumping all the cheese on a
spaghetti that all makes the time we've
spent getting to know these characters
feel worth it the ending also manages to
be hopeful while there's all that
impending catastrophe right under the
surface as a big fan of margot and the
ways they've made her a complicated
character that part of things was
particularly tough but i do like that
bending the rules for something that
seems like it's for the greater good is
much easier for her to navigate
emotionally than being intimate with
someone she clearly cares about in
sergey obviously what the kgb agent told
her was correct good intentions aside
she really did walk right into it and
because she's given her life to the job
in the space program the weak spots that
will be her downfall are completely
believable i guess the one silver lining
is that her close colleague now happens
to have a job that comes with get out of
jail free cards but losing the work
that's gonna crush her in her later
years as much as i am hoping to see ed
knock danny stevens down a peg i'm still
sentimentally rooting for nasa in this
race the crane shot after the time jump
at mission control where you watch
eleida come out from behind the flight
desk pretty much says it all they may
now be the past and ed not being able to
get there first again would be somewhat
disappointing but nothing else about
helios has brought me on board yet the
jury is still out on deb iesa but
especially on my second watch the way he
did that quick turn with ed it just came
off as suspicious rather than anything
else you do have to hand it to them
though ed danny and their crew are
traveling in style compared to everyone
else i like that they didn't mess around
too much with the presidential race
since it seemed like an inevitability
that ellen would win but that also meant
that we didn't get to spend much time
with the character which is kind of a
shame the reveal was pretty fantastic
though and i'm sure we'll get more of
her as this race heats up as a layman
the sojourner one wasn't very exciting
when we finally saw it to me it just
looked like a bigger version of the
shuttles that they use with some
modifications it's very possible that
i'm missing something and it's weird
that we haven't been introduced to four
out of the six people that are on it i
was a little surprised that we didn't
see molly in helios mission control i do
wonder what she's been up to for the
last two years and i think that is a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you thought about
the episode and how you think things are
gonna play out there are a lot of
different possibilities and a lot of
potential so let me know what you think
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon